just about everybody in the countries
got a smartphone spending a day without
going online is unfathomable to almost
all of us tech rules our lives to an
ever greater degree but the so called
digital frontier is getting fenced in
it's not quite as broad as we were told
it would be a handful of companies now
have almost total control over what we
can say do or see on the internet
control of almost all human information
consider Facebook about half the country
uses it as a primary news source
millions and millions of people
understand the world through Facebook
but Facebook is not a neutral host it
has a political agenda
earlier this year Facebook altered its
algorithms for what news stories its
users see and the results conclusively
have been devastating
for conservatives online Breitbart the
news site has basically lost about 30%
of its traffic since that happened
Prager you down 32% Daily Caller is down
rare closed its doors
some reports say I J R is on the brink
of collapse because of it Fox by the way
is down too meanwhile purveyors of
approved elite opinion CNN The New York
Times The Washington Post
they've been unaffected by this what is
this well it's an act of ideological
warfare and it's far more worrying than
anything that Cambridge analytic has
done or is accused of doing SOI Brown
found in Western journal calm as a lunar
site hit big by the changes at Facebook
and he joins us tonight Floyd this is
not just the primer dream on the right
that Facebook is somehow singling out in
effect conservative sites the numbers
are really clear how is this working
well it's very clear and I would say
that Facebook has broken its trust with
the end user you know one of the things
I always liked about Facebook and
admired about Facebook was that it was
optimized to the end user you have about
1.5 million followers on Facebook Tucker
and the truth is is as one of those
followers I expect to get news and
information that you find interesting
and you decide to share that's a social
network it's no longer a social network
when Mark Zuckerberg and the
other elites in Silicon Valley decide
what you should get the the information
that you should consume and and really
decide from on high what news
you should have how do we get to a place
where one company or along with Google
really two companies control all online
media both political companies and
without any oversight at all by anybody
can just shut down sites they disagree
with how did we get to that place well I
think that early on Facebook did a
fabulous job of letting people basically
curate their own content we all went
online and we we like different people
we followed Donald Trump we followed you
know people in the news that we liked we
followed publications that we liked and
so we were all of a sudden getting you
know great content that we just all we
all wanted to follow it and consume it
and so as a result of that Facebook went
through the roof but now Facebook's
having trouble with engagement because
it's not optimized to the end user
anymore it's now optimized to the
thought police and that's a big change
that's really it's hurting Facebook but
it's also hurting discourse in America
and it also Tucker and this is I think
what people need to understand on
Capitol Hill is it has big implications
for upcoming elections and really the
ability of America to make good
decisions it's another form of social
control of course
Floyd thank you for that I appreciate
that